hello and welcome back to our channel
today we're going to be talking about an
anime goku having failed 19 job
interviews in one day jury's dream of
moving out of her parents home are
utterly dashed stuck living with her
working mother neat brother tsubasa
later father and single parent sister
the only hope for this family to raise a
decent adult is her little nephew makoto
later that day men belonging to a cult
called the genuine love society kidnaps
her brother and her nephew the
kidnappers called jury demanding that
they pay a ransom of 5 million yen in 30
minutes or else tsubasa and makoto are
killed unable to get the money in time
jury's grandfather brings out a special
stone that frees his time while allowing
himself jury and julie's father to move
freely in the still world called stasis
they arrive at the site where subasa and
makoto are being held captive to rescue
them however the three are surprised to
find out that they aren't the only ones
who can move in stasis as a bunch of men
arrive to ambush them while one of them
attempts to kill makoto a giant monster
suddenly appears in front of everybody
at the hideout the monster called a
handler kills the cult member who
attempted to kill the motionless makoto
grandfather uses his teleportation
powers to get himself and jewry out of
danger while jury's father gets captured
a group of cultists led by majima are
ordered to capture grandfather having
escaped the pursuers jury decides to
learn how to teleport but is unable to
do so having decided to redo the time
freeze grandfather heads to the hideout
to find answers as to how those men were
able to move in stasis while jury heads
home to get the stone meanwhile tsubasa
is able to move and he helps out a still
frozen makoto grandfather arrives at the
hideout and learns that the cult had
been spying on the family and was
waiting for them to enter stasis
meanwhile jury returns home and gets
ambushed by cultists after finding out
that they're taking the stone
suddenly jewelry awakens a hidden power
that can freeze those who can move in
stasis by expelling their spectre a
lifeform that grants those with the
ability to move in stasis jury uses the
power to take back the stone and escape
meanwhile a handler comes to kill a
cultist who is about to murder a man
while the majima orders her men to
capture jury alive makoto gets a specter
and is able to move in stasis and he
goes around being curious about the
still world jewry and grandfather are
pursued by cult members who are fully
aware of the latter's teleportation
ability but the two managed to get away
they were together in the middle of the
road so they could have time to react
should they get spotted by the cult
however a cult member posing as one of
the stored humans launches a surprise
attack on jewry the cult member is
intercepted by grandfather and jury
expels his spectre to freeze him
grandfather recalls the time he became
aware of jury's ability as 17 years ago
jury invertedly used the same power on
him and was nearly frozen from it later
the two pursued more cultists and unable
to teleport away from them jury uses her
power to make them motionless the two
head to the hideout to get tsubasa and
makoto but find them missing unaware
that they'd escaped as a result of being
given specters meanwhile a handler kills
one of the cultists for attempting to
kill a motionless person in front of
majima and she sees it collapse majima
finds out that a handler called a herald
by the cult has a dead corpse inside it
seventeen years ago majima and her
family entered the stasis able to move
her brother and parents all became
handlers while she encountered jury who
expelled her specter to save her from
becoming a handler this made her join
the cult that she could get jury to use
that power again that could bring her
family back
jury and grandfather arriving jury uses
her power in front of majima later jury
with her grandfather rescues takafumi
but he's hesitant to go with them
meanwhile the cult decides to try and
murder a motionless man with various
degree of intent to determine the
threshold for when a handler takes
action the handler appears majima sees
that it's her mother that's inside it
along the way jury warned subasa and
makoto not to stay at the house having
written a note but after those two
arrived at home occultists had removed
the letter and attacks the two knowing
that handlers don't take action against
those killing a moving person tsumasa
takes on the cultists and tells makoto
to run during the fight he gets stabbed
but fortunately the wound isn't deadly
and he manages to defeat the cultist and
escape shortly afterwards he starts to
transform into a handler jury arrives
just in time to expel his spectre before
his transformation is complete and
tsubasa becomes motionless jury's father
expresses his displeasure for being
rescued claiming that he was trying to
be a spy makoto is kidnapped by majima's
partner and majima approaches jury
asking her to use her power on the
handler which jury agrees to do despite
disapproving of her actions majima tries
to kill a motionless man to draw the
handler but her murderous intent was too
weak to draw it out after jury's father
quietly builds up the murderous intent
the handler arrives to kill him but
fortunately the grandfather uses his
teleportation ability to save him as the
handler is trying to kill jury's father
she jumps on the monster and after a
long struggle she expels the specters
thus saving her father after handler
collapses the corpses of majima's family
come out majima expressed her gratitude
towards her dead parents for recognizing
her for a moment however her brother is
still alive
having resolved majima's conflict jury
decides to destroy the stone as soon as
they exit stasis after learning about
the tragedy that befell the majima
family but without dakafumi knowing
about the plan to do that jury must
expel the specters from all cult members
still able to move in stasis with majima
and her partner cutting ties with the
cult to help her out meanwhile cult
leader sagawa explains that the stasis
power is tied to bloodlines while
telling his disciples that he intends to
harness the power of stasis to live as
long as he can leading to a moral divide
within the cult while majima and her
partner are talking to a cult member
jury and grandfather teleport to their
location and she expels the specter out
of one of the cult members while two of
the cult members find the stone that was
hidden on a tree and informed sagawa in
his final sermon sagawatt tells his
disciples that he's mastered the power
of the handlers sagawa transforms into a
handler but unlike the other handlers he
harnesses its powers while maintaining a
full control of his body sagawa then
starts killing his disciples one of the
disciples attempts to kill subasa but
jury arrives and expels his spectre
sagawa tries to kill jury but
grandfather teleports her out of danger
majima approaches sagawa's most loyal
disciple shiomi trying to help jury's
cause but he declines out of fear for
his safety mindy might encounter sagawa
again and she gets cornered and then
jewelry and grandfather arrive to save
her xiaomi arrives and slash his
grandfather's hand to collect his blood
she only puts a drop of his blood in the
stone and grandfather experiences great
pain as he's about to become motionless
with his last bit of strength before
becoming one of the stalled grandfather
teleports with jury to the stone's
location jewelry smashes the stone to
stop grandfather from becoming
motionless but by doing so the means of
existing stasis is gone sagawa attacks
and due to the stone being destroyed
xiomi decides to betray sagawa and help
jury and grandfather escape majima
mentions that there is another way to
leave the stasis by expelling everybody
specters but jewry would remain trapped
in stasis xiaomi tells everybody what
sagawa's goal is to see the world far
into the future and because he's killing
people to achieve this goal that he's
got to be stopped meanwhile a handler
attacks takafumi but makoto is able to
stop it as he awakens his power to
communicate with handlers jewelry and
company arrive at the scene and the
handler is revealed to be one of the
cult members that sagar killed after his
final sermon everybody realizes now that
they have the handlers fighting on their
side with everybody mistakenly thinking
that takafumi and not makoto controls
the handler that he takes advantage of
the situation to clear his name
jury and company launch an attack on
sagawa using the handler to distract him
while jury expels his spectre but is
unable to do so however sagavar exhausts
his power and loses his human form and
retreats jewelry and grandfather track
him down at the house where sagomar
proposes a way for everybody to make it
out of stasis but jewry is highly
skeptical sagawa explains his backstory
as he was a shinto priest training to
succeed his father and had lived a
sheltered life he didn't have many
friends but he had a close friend one
day the two of them caught sagawa's
father and his friend's mother having a
sexual affair which led to sagawa
condemning his father and eventually led
to the creation of the genuine love
society sagawa concludes his backstory
saying that he found out about the
stasis stone when his father died five
years after the incident after hearing
his story jury goes through her intended
course of action by expelling his
specter but her power has no effect on
him so she tries to kill him instead not
wanting julie to be burdened by killing
someone her grandfather attempts to kill
him but he's still too weak to do it
suddenly jury's father appears and kills
sagawa his body dissolves leaving only
his brain then his brain flies out to
the window and shoots out threads all
over the place that cuts takafumi's
fingers while he was trying to reach the
brain jury expels taka forming spectra
to prevent blood loss while they're
observing the threads the brain turns
into a strange shape looking like a star
and xiaomi figures out that they're used
for nourishment and are made of specters
later jury uses her powers to remove the
specter from her brother to remove him
from stasis meanwhile sagawa's threads
are slowly spreading having majima
trapped among them jury cuts the threads
to save manjima leading to sagavar
starving to death afterwards sagawa is
reborn as a baby
confident that sagawa's memories will
not return jury decides to raise him as
her son she sends all remaining
inhabitants out of stasis except sagawa
and grandfather she intends to raise him
in the stasis until he's mature enough
to handle himself in the real world
after helping jury raise sagawa for a
while grandfather is sent out of stasis
leaving just jewry and sagawa after half
a year passes in stasis sagawa is sent
back as time passes in the stasis for
jury she begins to break down mentally
and begins her transformation into a
handler however she was saved when she
has a chance encounter with the wife of
the stone's creator that died in 1880
the creator's wife who's the original
founder of the stasis returns jury to
the real world and reunites her with her
family years later since that fateful
day sagawa has grown up and treasures
his new family
so this is it for today's video if you
like the video give it a huge thumbs up
and subscribe to the channel for more
videos farewell till next time